[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Merhabalar
tedx'in sahnesi beni ağırlıyor sizleri
ağırlıyor ama ben de Yıldız Teknik
Üniversitesi
ailesinin bir mensubu olarak sizleri
burada ağırlamaktan büyük mutluluk
duyduğumuzu söylemek isterim
malum akademisyenlik kanımıza işlemiş
diğer konuşmacılardan farklı olarak
benim küçük notlarım var Ara sıra bakmam
lazım Çünkü tanıyanlar bilir Biz
akademisyenler hele ben verdiniz mi
konuşalım diye elimize kozu hiç susmak
bilmeye biliriz O yüzden bazı küçük
notlar aldım
bu konuşma için
PC'de ilk maili e postayı Gördüğüm Zaman
tedx nedir falan bir okudun Yani önce
çok şaşırdım çok onarı oldum fakat
gerçekten çok korktum daha bir ay önce
bu sahnede 1500 kişiye hoş geldiniz
dedim ama bugün burada bulunmak
inanılmaz bir sorumluluk benim için
Çünkü beni bir kadın olarak
cins taşlarıma ya da meslek
ortağımdakilere
bir rol modeli olarak düşünmüşler Bu
açıdan biraz korktum ve etrafımdaki çok
yakın dostlarıma
bir de kızımdı onlara sordum ben ne
diyeceğim Ne anlatacağım dedim yani
hayat hikayemi nasıl anlatayım
sonra yani bunları yapmak benim için çok
doğal şeylerdi dedim açıkçası İşte o
noktada kızım şeydir işte Sen bunu
anlatacaksın dedi Yani bu senin dedi
yaşam biçimin ailem de bunu kabul etti
onlarla ilgilenme süremin yanında okulda
geçirdiğim Hayat bütün hayatım Burası
diye ve aklıma gelenleri ufak ufak not
aldım hatta bu not alma işim sabah
gündüz oturumundaki ilham verici çok
ilham verici genç kadınlarımızı
dinlerken hem duygulandım hem inanılmaz
gurur duydum ben ilk
kadın Mimar değilim
ilk kadın akademisyen diyelim ilk kadın
Mimar akademisyen de değilim
ama kadınların bu camiada çeşitli
şekillerde
varoluşuna katkıda bulunduğunuza da
inanıyorum kadın Mimar ve akademisyeni
olarak
Biraz önce bir post paylaştım
dışarıda çektik ve altına buraya gelmek
50 yıl sürdü diye yazdım
her şey çok kolay elde edemiyoruz ama
gerçekten de çaba harcamamız ve çok
çalışmamız gerekiyor
bize öykümü Öykü mü hikaye artık nasıl
anlatsam diye düşündüm ve üçe ayırmaya
karar verdim
ve bunu yazarken
Apple vardı aklımda ama
yuvarlak masamızı hatırladım Mutfaktaki
ve bir Dün değil evvelsi gün annemle
babama da bu konuşmamı hem de zaman
tutmak adına onlarla paylaştım ve gene o
aynı masa vardı okuldan gelip o masa
etrafındaki ikindi kahvaltılarımız akşam
yemeklerimiz ve pazar öğle yemeklerimiz
babamın iş durumu nedeniyle öğle
yemekleri Ancak pazar günü bir araya
gelirdik ve o ortam Aslında bizim bütün
iletişimimizi köklü bir aile olmanın
köklerini görmenin daha büyük
ebeveynlerimizden de bize katıldığı
olurdu ilk tohumları orada atılmış
çok normal ortada direkt bir aileyiz Biz
Babam annem ben ve iki erkek kardeşim
var 3 çocuklu bir aile
Bu arada iki erkek kardeşim
Mimarlık okudu Ama benden daha eğlenceli
insanlar olduklarını söyleyebilirim
biri bu çok heyecanlı zamanda hem de
Türkiye'deki ilklerden diğeri de çok
küçük
13-14 yaşında evden kaçar rallilere
seyretmeye giderdi benim öyle havalı
hobilerim ya da işlerim olmadı diyeyim
size
beni etkileyen ilk Ailemde Annem ve
babam annem ev kadını çok okur ama
cidden çok okur evine ne geçerse okur
başucunda işte Klasikler var şunlar var
ve ben onu her okuduğunu sonraki kuşak
Ben devralarım okumak için
Ama şu anda bile durup baktığım zaman
onun 3 çocuk o zamanlar ev işleri
arkadaşları alışverişler içinde bütün
bunu nasıl zaman ayırdığını bilmiyorum
herhalde bu onun rahatlamaz
yoluydu sığınaydı babam
ailemizin başı Hala da öyle Mimar
İstanbul Teknik Okulu 1960 mezunu yani
Yıldız Teknik Üniversitesi'nin Bir
önceki hali Yıldız Teknik Yıldız
üniversite Üniversitesi İstanbul'da
devlet mühendisi ondan da önceki halinde
o da kendi alanında oldukça
önderlik eden bir kişi olmuş ve bizim
geniş ailemizin ilk üniversite mezunu
olarak göz bebeği Babam da fotoğraf
çekmek gezmek ve projeciliğin en bariz
özellikleri diyebilirim Türkiye'nin her
yerine gidip çalışır projeler
uygulamalar yapardı
ve sonra ben oldum diyeyim size doğduğum
anlamında değilim bu hale gelmemde
kendimi özetlemek istersen okumaya ve
öğrenmeye Tutkun gerçekten öğrenmeye
bayılıyorum hala öğrencilerimden Yani
hala demiyim hep böyle bir yaşam biçimi
bu fotoğraf çekmeyi ve gezmeyi çok ama
çok severim ve her konuda da hep
söyleyeceğim bir şey vardır Bu yüzden de
biraz ukala diye de bulunurum ki biraz
da bu aslında biz zavallı mimarlara
diyeyim Bir etikette olmuyor değil her
şeyde biliyorsunuz diyorlar ve biliyoruz
böyle bir kadın oldum Mimar oldum
anne oldum akademisyen oldum arkadaş
oldum sevgili oldum
aile maceram böyle olsun Şimdi ben diğer
konuşmacılara da sonrasında programda
eğlendirip görünce eyvah dedim ben orada
ne yapacağım dedim çünkü şu açıdan şimdi
belirli bir yıl olarak bu kadar bir
zaman yaşayınca deneyimlerinizi de çok
fazla oluyor ve şeyden korktum o fosil
gibi görünmeyeyim dedim işte Benim
zamanımda böyle o yüzden Detaylara
girmeyeceğim biraz da eğitimden size
bahsedeyim eğitim hayatım çok böyle
başarıyla falan başlamış değil Ben
hatırlamıyorum ama bunu Annem söylemişti
yine
ilk okulda
Belki daha büyükler varsa bile
bilmiyorum şu anda yapılıyor mu okumayı
çözenlere Kırmızı Kurdele takılırdı
böyle yakasına ben en son bana takılmış
Hatta Annemin dediğine göre öğretmenim
çok üzülmüş hani diğer çocukları okudu
bu okuyamadı ona da takalım demiş
kurdeleyi Bilemiyorum artık Annem ama
şey diyor söyledi bir okudun diyor Bir
daha senin durduramadık diyor
güzel bir şey okumak diye düşünüyorum
Sonra lise doğru gidince çok güzel bir
Lisede okudum devlet bir ses öyle şey
değil
herkes gibi dönemimdeki bütün gençler
gibi kime sorsanız Doktor olmak
istiyordu benimle eksiğim var tabii ki
ben de doktor olmak istiyordum sonra
TRT'de bir belgeselde böyle Göz kapağına
çevirdiler falan bir şeyler bir ameliyat
gibi bir şey gösteriyordu Ben de her
Vazgeçtim ondan Ama hala da bir Tıp
istiyorum Yani bir Tıp istiyorum
ve şey diyalog olayım ben dedim biyoloji
O kim dedim ben
anneme biyoloji hocası olup da ne
yapacaksın dedi Biz çok söz dinleyen bir
nesilde peki dedim bende
ve
içimdeki cevherin çıkması için mimarlığa
girmem gerekiyormuş dönüp baktığım zaman
Ben daha ilkokuldayken babamın bürosuna
gidip şablonla yazı yazardım pastaları
olmuş çünkü o yaşta yapabileceğim tek
kişi oydu
şimdi baktığımda lisans eğitim sürem
dahil 40 yıldır akademik yaşamdayım
ortam demiyorum yaşamıyorum bu bir yaşam
biçimi Çünkü
Mimar Sinan ve itüdeki eğitim
yolculuklarım Yıldız Teknik
Üniversitesi'nde
Hoca olmayı öğrenmekle devam etti hala
devam ediyor ve biraz daha buralarda da
kalacağım gibi görünüyor Şimdi
birazcık Bu mesleğin kattıkları Çünkü
adına meslek diyoruz ama bu bir yaşam
biçimi bunu bir daha vurgulamak
istiyorum
Türkiye'nin Belki de Mimarlık ortamına
yön veren Lider 3 Üniversitesinde Hani
lisans lisansüstü
yapmak sonra
akademik yaşama devam etmek benim Hem
kişisel hem de mesleki hem de
akademisyenlik konusundaki becerilerimin
bilgi ve becerilerimin gelişmesine büyük
katkısı oldu entelektüel yapımı belki
ortaya koydu diyeyim belki de değil yani
o oluşturdu ve
bazıları eski bulsa da bunu ben bilgi
güçtür noktasına çok inanıyorum Tabii ki
bu gücü iyi kullanmak gerekiyor bilmek
yeni bir şeyler öğrenmek benim için
yaşamın anlamı hep Analitik düşünüyorum
dürüstlük eşitlik ve adalet konularında
da saplantılıyımdır diyebilirim eşit
olamayacağım insanlara davranamayacağım
diye de gerçekten çok çekinirim bu
konuda çok ince düşünürüm böyle de
olması gerektiğini açıkçası düşünüyorum
ayırma yapmanız hiç gerekli değil
ve Suat analizi gibi bir hayatım eğitim
hayatım oldu diyebilirim yani tehditler
ve zayıflıkları dönüp baktığım zaman
fırsatlara ve güçlü
çalışmalara çevirmek için çalıştım ve
çok çalıştım bunu şu anda yaptığım demin
arkadaşımız da söyledi Öğrenci
dekanlarında ilk açılış dersinde
üniversite yaşamına girişte 1 sınıf
öğrencilerine söylüyorum ki bunu sadece
ben söylemiyorum Tüm bu konuda
çalışanlar söylüyor Çok çalışmak çok
çalışmak çok çalışmazsanız kimse size
aslında bir şey vermiyor ve önceki
konuşmalarda da hepimiz mevcut olduk Çok
özverili çalışmalarla
genç kadınlarımızın nerelere geldiğini
gördük meslek olarak devam edersem bu
eğitimin getirdiklerini tabi bunları
böyle sıralı anlatınca biri bitiyor
öbürü başlıyor gibi değil aslında hepsi
birbiri içinde evrilerek devam ediyor ve
Mimar akademisyen bir de yanına bir
yöneticilik de eklendi
Ben mimar olarak benim en şey konum
mevcut çevrelerde yeni yapı tasarımı Bu
konuda da ilk değilim ama neredeyse
Türkiye'deki ilk doktorlardan yani 5-6
tane sayılırsa onlardan biriyim konu
aslında hiç eskimedi Hatta daha da
evrilip Sürdürülebilir yaşam haline
geldi yani bizim işimiz Sadece bina
yapmak değil aslında bir yaşam
tasarlamak Dolayısıyla
gene çalışma konumu
çok seviyorum çok faydalarını gördüm hep
onu geliştirdim gene konuşmacılarımızdan
Didem karaçın o lafını çok sevdim
doğru ayakkabıları seçmektedir ben onu
dinleyince doğru ayakkabıları seçtiğimi
düşündüm hem eğitim hayatımda hem diğer
pek çok konuda
bir diğer şey
öğrencilerimle ilişkilerimle ilgili
söylemek isterim Demin de biraz
bahsettim
ilişkisel düşünmek insanlar mekanlar
olaylar arasındaki Bağları anlamak
onları bir araya getirmek irdelemek
yorumlamak potansiyelleri görmek bizim
mesleğimizin kazanımları Aslında Bunlar
Bir mesleğin kazanımları gibi görünüyor
ama Aslında sizin yaşama karşı
duruşunuzu da sizin belirliyor
Bu yüzden biz mimarlar için uzlaştırıcı
kolaylaştırıcı dendiğini de söylemek
isterim
ve çok sevdiğim bir Amerikalı filozof
1895 doğumlusu senlenge bir sözü var
Mimarlık bütün çevrenin görünür kılınmış
biçimidir diyor
Dolayısıyla Mimarlık gerçekten bir
meslek olmaktan öte bir yaşam yaratmak
açısından hem benim hayatımı hem de
çalıştığım insanların da hayatını
dokunmamda çok büyük bir faydası var
birçok uzatmayacağım Son olarak size
şunu söylemek istiyorum Tüm hikayeyi
anlatmayacağım hepiniz biliyorsunuz Hani
Bir profesörün sınıfa getirdiği büyük
bir tane şey var cam kavanoz var işte
taşlar Çakıllar kumlar getiriyor Hatta
geçenlerde Sayın rektörümüz Tamer hoca
da bir yerde bahsetti hatta birisi şey
dedi hangisini koyarsın kumları dedi yok
dedim ben taşlar evet dedi Tamer hoca da
aile eğitimi meslek Kavanozdaki büyük
taşlarımdı
Küçük Çakıllar ve Kum olmazsa olmadığını
siz de biliyorsunuz
en başta kızım Hayat eşim öğrencilerim
hocalarım dostlarım benim nefes almamı
sağlıyorlar onlarla birlikte olmak
sizin de kendi Çevrenizde bir bakın Hiç
Kimse yalnız olmamalı diye düşünüyorum
sevimli postlarda gördünüz kısa bir
özetini verdik Hepsini yaptım orada
yazının fazlasını da yaptım daha da
yapmaya devam edeceğim 3 tane daha kitap
yazmayı düşünüyorum ama onları artık
emekli olunca yapacağım niye bunu
söyledim orada yazanlar orada
yazanlardır
ama
bu öğüt gibi olacak işte son kapatırken
bunların yanında Önemli olan
hayatınızdaki insanlardır hep kendiniz
dışındakiler ile ilişki kuracaksınız
onları düşüneceksiniz arkanızda mutsuz
birini bırakmayacaksınız onlara daha iyi
yaşam olanakları sunacaksınız Hatta bu
sadece insanlarda olmayacak Her şeyi
aşkla tutkuyla yapacaksınız tutkusuz
hiçbir şey olmaz mesleği işi bir yaşama
dönüştüğün her şey Sizin ona duyduğunuz
tutkudur Bu benim yolumdu sizlerin kendi
yolunuzu bulmanızı ve bunda başarıyla
ilerlemenizi diliyorum beni dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]